okay yeah
i'll speak about our
platform section for chime
and
chime is a tool that analyzes meta
genomics data this culture independent
microbial communities what we basically
learn about them is composition and
function of
these communities
and it can be
applied in a bunch of areas like
agriculture where you can study soil
properties or any bacteria driven
processes in healthcare where we can
study microbiome
microbiomes of different organs
or ecology where
biosensors are developed using
metagenomics and by degradation of
plastic is also bacteria during process
and of course biotechnology
the nutrition produced or
pharmaceuticals or biofuel everything is
done thanks to bacteria
so um
basically when we sample our data and we
extract dna um
and then we want to amplify it we can go
two ways we can either go a whole genome
sequencing way or target sequencing way
and in case we want only to sequence the
target
16s
ribosomal rna is
the region that mostly is targeted in
bacteria because it has both conserved
and hypervariable regions actually there
are nine just they didn't have a picture
good enough for
to include it
but this higher variable regions help us
differentiate between
different species
so
16 as
um or
target sequencing or amplicon sequencing
it's cheap compared to whole genome
sequencing it's pretty standard we
already know all the primers so it's
easier to conduct
but it's restricted to previously known
an annotated taxa and sometimes it's not
enough to differentiate between the
samples
also we only get the compositional
information we don't know any function
that are done here
whole genome sequencing allows us to
study novel organisms and we can
assemble the reads in
and we can run functional genomics and
understand what uh function this
organelles does
it's also more information on to
differentiate between the taxa but there
are a bunch of problems uh to hold
genome sequencing of bacterias
because it's expensive it's hard to
understand what is contamination what is
not
and so on
so on the platform we present three
modules uh pre-processing that
consists of filtering and denoising
algorithms and we go on to taxonomy with
silver classification
filtering our classified sequences and
conducting philogenetic trees then we
can move on to metrics to calculate for
alpha and beta diversity
so um at the very beginning we start
with the quality control and it's very
important not to include um regions of
flow quality because they will interfere
with all the downstream analysis with
our abundances with our philogenetic
tree and taxonomy and everything so you
have to um
understand where you want to trim your
wrists like this so you will not include
low quality nucleotides in your
downstream analysis
so after filtering the replication we
come to denoising or clustering
techniques
so the idea is that when we first
assemble our data or we have
um one sec well sequence per species or
something like that but when we run
amplification there are bound to be some
errors and we get small fractions of
sequences that are slightly different
from our original one
and when we sequence there are even more
errors and more unique sequences and so
we end up with a plethora of
unique sequences and um classics
clustering algorithms
would look for the most abundant
sequence and design it as a center
and cluster everything um that is 97
similar in one cluster
um
well there are a few problems with this
approach the first is that not all the
species are 97 similar some are a lot
more similar
and
researchers came up with another
approach to noisy
which was taking into account different
models of errors and sequence same
quality calls
to try and correct uh the errors the
mistakes and
end up with hellotypes but these
haplotypes
are 100 similar
so after denoising or clustering um
for paired entries there is also option
to merge well not an option it's a
little step to merge the reads
um since uh even for targeted sequencing
we can pick different size uh different
regions and the size of region may uh
vary and sometimes the reads are
separated like this
sometimes they overlap and for example
data too treats them a bit differently
in case they overlap they only take the
part that overlaps and in case they
overhang it will take one of the reads
and if they are separated it will
concatenate the reads together
so
when we sampled our data extracted dna
amplified it and did the noising we end
up with a table like this where we have
counts of each unique representative
sequence per sample
and here we can ask ourselves
three main questions uh first is how
similar or different the things are in
one sample and that will be alpha
diversity
um second question is how similar
difference are the samples between each
other that will be beta diversity
and the third is what specifically leads
to differences between the samples and
that will be a taxonomic profile and
we'll start with the third one
so for taxonomy analysis it is uh
strongly advised to use the same primers
that you used for yours
for your uh
data
so
the same region will be extracted from
the database um here we use silver
database that has been updated and
curated
um
and you can see the
mostly used primers here and primary
sequences so you just take the sequence
add it to the platform forward and
reverse
primers
and they will extract exact regions from
the database
and run classification so it will look
for
if this sequence
is in the
silver database and it will assign
taxonomic unit to the sequences
and you will end up with a bar plot
showing
what bacteria
are there in your samples
if you want some of them removed you can
exclude them
just type the correct
name of the taxa or if maybe you want to
include just
several samples so you can do the same
and you can also group the samples based
on
some categorical columns in your
metadata for example i was interested in
body sites to see if
samples from god were any different from
palms and tongue
so after taxonomy analysis we go on to
a genetic tree so this is um
this will show how similar our
representative sequences are
and it starts from multiple sequence
alignment and then
the there are a few algorithms are
available to
build the tree fast tree
and iq tree
this is mainly used for core metrics but
you can also extract the tree and
visualize it and for example fig tree or
any other tool that helps visualize
photogenetic tree files
so after that
we have
looking at this table the artificial i
just came up with it to show um
looking at this table we see that um
total counts for each samples are
different and
in case we can
compare sample four and sample one
they're pretty close in total counts um
we can't really compare example three
with others right
so because they have different sampling
depth and we can't really run any
reliable statistics on something like
this so one of the ways out is to
subsample the frequencies um
so that the total count will be the same
for all the samples like here
so we subsample um
all the table and
change the table
so that the total will be the same
and
this is
not ideal because we'll lose information
sometimes we even lose whole samples if
their uh sampling depth is lower than
uh what would peak
but this is a good way
to normalize your sample so the
statistics will be reliable
but how actually
should we pick the value um
for example how did i pick 100
we should be looking at our samples and
their sampling depth now for example
here
we can see that some samples have
sampling depths lower than 1000 some
have
something depth a bit less than 2000
some are here but the majority are
having bigger sampling depth also we can
see that the number features are quite
stable starting from here so it looks
like this region
um looks appropriate to take the sound
in depth
um
but if i
it's also very meaningful to look at
your groups and if the samples in your
groups of interests are still there for
example if i take sampling depth of 2000
my right palm sample group will be
almost will consist of only two or three
samples
but if i take sampling times 1000 my
right palm group will be okay i can
still work with it
the only thing that is left is core
metrics basically calculating all the
metrics for alpha and beta diversity
using the sampling depth that we just um
identified
and it will give us an idea so the alpha
diversity was give us an idea how things
are inside the sample
basically uh telling us how rich and
even our samples with different indices
shannon index pillar index
and beta diversity um will give us an
understanding how samples
are between each other
plotting pca based on different
distances like jakarta or
baycurtis and we also can run
permanova test
on a column that we are interested in in
this case it was bodyside and
i got really good p-value meaning that
this
group has very different
beta diversity statistics
that's it thank you very much for your
intention and uh yeah here i just is
mentioning some studies that were done
using amplicon and whole genome sequence
in mathematic genomics
thank you